did we ever talk about how I asked you
to do stars born did we ever talk about
that I've never told anyone because I
because I felt bad for the guy who got
the role I didn't want to like you want
to talk about that can I talk about it I
I I would I mean such a
great again Howard we shave your head we
and you were open to it yeah I because I
well the thing was I love you know the
thing about Howard uh to me is you know
he was this mythological figure then I
still remember how many times I've done
the show three maybe but the first time
I remember and I saw you in person I
couldn't believe how gentle your eyes
are how kind your eyes are like you
can't even hide it as much of an [__]
you try to be to me it's like well look
how kind his eyes are it's impossible
it's just impossible to hate the guy I
will tell you this like I've told two or
three people in my life that you offered
me that role in A Star is Born yeah and
they look at me like what the [__] you
didn't do it I go no I think the guy who
ended up doing the role was fantastic
just for so so it's clear that was
before like you know the role that was
written was written for the person that
played it there was no this this was
this was early early things swimming in
my head uh you know when I offered it to
you it's not like he got it's not like
it was a totally different role yeah I
came to you thinking well here you go
you got it well you came to me and you
said hey you will play my brother and I
went whoa you must think I'm a lot
better looking than they're going to be
like what the [__] what is it this movie
going to be like twins I'm Danny DeVito
and he's Arnold schwarzeneger or
something I don't know what the hell's
going on here but you said I'm going to
play your older brother yeah and I'm
going to be like your manager type thing
your agent or manager yeah and I went no
[__] that's kind of intriguing I said
I'm going to go full on like into it I'm
going to shave my head I'm going to
change my whole look I was really you
know toying with the idea you yeah you
said give me a couple weeks I mean you
it wasn't like you said no right away
there was I feel like there were three
weeks of me sort of standing by right
yeah like you really contemplated this
yeah I would have won him an Oscar too I
mean it would have been awesome me at
the Oscar winning when we start talking
about you shaving your head that was
very exciting yeah yeah can you imagine
oh it would have been amazing yeah we
maybe we'll do one day you know what I
me I think it's going to happen man I
think it's going to happen I just got I
have to figure out the right thing to so
that you'll say
yes